[Music]
the cmas were dreaming of a better
tomorrow
as justin joined dan and shay at an
empty hollywood bowl stage in california
to sing their mega hit ten thousand
hours all three had a ton to celebrate
the song just hit 500 million streams on
spotify plus
dan and shea picked up vocal duo of the
year in a time like this
i feel like it is very important that we
tell the people that we love that we
love them so i love you dude
mayor morris was certainly feeling the
love winning her first female vocalist
of the year award
as well as single and song of the year
for the bones
and during her final speech of the night
marin used that moment to spotlight
a group of women too often overlooked in
country music
linda martell yola mickey guyton
rissy palmer
britney spencer randon giddens
there are so many amazing black women
that pioneered and continue to pioneer
this genre
and i know they're going to come after
me they've come before me but
you've made this genre so so beautiful i
hope you know that we see you
i just felt like as female vocalists of
this year of 2020
i wanted to share that moment with
these women that don't often get the
credit that they deserve
other winners included eric church who
picked up his first entertainer of the
year award
and spoke backstage about how covet 19
has impacted the industry
i would look out every night and i would
see people with their boots in the air
or their drink in the air and i would
try to take a mental
picture and i'll be honest i might have
taken that for granted after coke
because i never thought i wouldn't see
it again
and coronavirus loomed large over the
cmas which were hosted by reba mcintyre
and darius rucker in front of a small
live audience in nashville who are
notably
not wearing masks now in a statement the
cmas addressed the controversy
saying quote every single person was
required to be tested
staff and crew are also required to wear
ppe at all times
tables are spaced eight feet apart with
no more than four people seated per
table
but before the show even started kovit
hit the cmas pretty hard
with lady a pulling out because someone
in their camp tested positive
the same went for an unspecified member
of rascal flatts
florida georgia alliance tyler hubbard
and lee bryce who ended up winning the
award for musical event of the year
with carly pierce it's really special
that we all get to at least
be together and see each other and
experience
some sort of normalcy as far as bringing
country music to
fans